[Musique]
à 230 km au nord de montréal
on arrive dans la capitale des hautes
laurentides mont laurier
avec un peu plus de 14 mille habitants
s'est lavé la plus populeuse dans le
vaste territoire de la mrc d'antoine
labelle région réputée pour la chasse et
la pêche
le magasin le coureur des bois est
incontournable pour les passionnés de la
nature
lui c'est françois labelle le
propriétaire depuis 40 ans pour te
montrer l'est et le frigidaire à 100 sur
le méconnu ici notamment pour son
élevage de sangsues qui fait fureur
auprès des pêcheurs katlama paiement
comme soit pas trop parce que vraiment
bien vivante et les affaires sont bonnes
les articles de plein air ont la cote et
sa clientèle est lui nombreuses depuis
l'an passé avec l'arrivée de la pandémie
c'est la région étaient submergés de
tout le monde on voit qu encore plus de
monde à chaque achat qu chaque année qui
montrent de plus en plus parce qu'on
voit que plus un monde en région en
effet au cours des dernières années il y
a eu plus d'arrivées que de départs dans
les laurentides
le solde migratoire de la mrc d'antoine
labelle est passé de 94 en 2019 à 550 en
roberto et julie font partie de ces
nouveaux arrivants ils se sont
rencontrés il y a un an ils ont décidé
de quitter montréal et de s'acheter
cette maison située à ferme-neuve en
banlieue de mont laurier
moi mon loria par une pancarte vert du
jamais vu ça pour moi c'était fou un
changement radical qui s'est passé très
rapidement
il attira bertola karine traval d'achat
des rivaux de la fille que je l'envoie
ok c'est bon d'acquérir le faire une
douce folie que le couple qui travaille
en immobilier ne regrette pas des gens
qui laisse passer mon projet de retraite
bah ce projet les tons projet de
retraite le sap est ton projet de vie si
moi j'avais vraiment le désir d'essayer
un nouveau mode de vie aussi la ville je
connais à le café du coin est le
restaurant puis avec le déconfinement je
me dis je prends goût de retourner
vraiment ce mode de vie l'offre je pense
que on est aux balbutiements d'une prise
de conscience que la région nos valeurs
j'avais que si on déménage dans une
petite ville comme ici on n'était pas
loin de toute l'activité économique
quand même que je pense qu'étant
développement je croyais en la région
et justement depuis cinq ans mon le riz
est en pleine transformation
la revitalisation du centre-ville est en
cours un investissement de 8 millions de
dollars la route 117 qui traverse la
ville sera modernisée une salle de
spectacle multifonctionnel a été
construite au coût de 19 millions de
dollars
on projette aussi de fournir internet
haute vitesse sur tout le territoire
d'ici 2022
sans oublier le parc industriel de plus
de 4 millions de pieds carrés qui est en
plein essor 2008 on a commencé à
développer de le développer parce qu'on
n'avait aucune entreprise dans notre
parc industriel
après 25 ans sans activité les choses
bougent enfin l'entreprise forex prévoit
construire une importante usine de
transformation du bois
il sera et historique pour la ville de
mont-laurier ils vont investir dans le
parc industriel 220 millions pour créer
150 emplois en usine
alors pour nous mais je vous en reparle
de jarnac chair de poule parce que notre
population à un autre
je l'appellerai parc industriel pour
falloir commencer à regarder connacht
enoch henry ce que vous est tout à fait
parce que 7 points
ah oui à paroles usine de fret on a
aussi une autre usine qui est le bio
produit aussi quelques autres c'est 50
millions environ alors voyez beaucoup
d'effervescence piano beau projet qu'on
ne touche pas c'est les plantations de
l'université du québec en
abitibi-témiscamingue qu'il allait
prochainement investir 10 millions de
dollars à mont-laurier bon la
construction d'un nouveau pavillon
on travaille pour avoir des gens parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui le moment
j'apprends des gens
[Musique]
ça
eric tardif est l'un de ces jeunes que
le maire tente d'attirer natif de
montréal
il est venu s'installer ici via 5 à
l'est devenu un fier ambassadeur de la
région quand je suis novice ray ça
c'était vraiment le coup de pub avec la
belle famille mais aussi vraiment que la
région il a démarré son entreprise
charcuterie un changement de vie complet
pour cet ancien charpentier
pour moi c'était une grosse échappée
d'un charcutier voudriez que je capable
de faire 65 de façon traditionnelle
j'ai parti un élevage de porcs juste
pour passer sous sol dans la région pour
moi si si tout s'est vraiment ses
membres qui est mis là dedans c'est le
travail de mon équipe c'est un travail
d'année il a maintenant 13 employés dont
son nouveau chef
fraîchement arrivé de montréal et sa
dernière réalisation
vous avez besoin d'un restaurant qui
offre est exclusivement des produits
régionaux
j'étais heureux de ce qui se passe est
spécialement parlé la dernière un an et
demi on a vraiment énormément de monde
qui vont venir de l'extérieur et décidé
de s'établir mont-laurier va revenir à
un peu à ça grogne est peut-être l'était
cac l'industrie faut verser était
vraiment énorme
elle avait vraiment il y avait un gros
boum ici effectivement une strie
progressive vraiment pris 1
un vrai manche était pas mal mais on
devient une région à gros trous c'est là
on montre qu'on a autre chose à offrir
dans ce week-end notre part ici que mon
laurier a été totalement une autre
visage
depuis 12 ans frédéric hohl travail pour
développer l'entrepreneuriat une
campagne publicitaire a été lancé l'an
dernier pour attirer les jeunes fut un
temps que dans la région c'était plus
des entrepreneurs par nécessité
maintenant je rendais gens qui ont
l'entrepreneuriat dans l'âme à tous les
jours le sans exagérer j'ai un nouvel un
nouveau client lucky qui veut qu'on la
compagne les offres d'emploi dans la mrc
ont doublé en un an et demi maintenant à
date ça sans offre d'emploi qui ont été
publiées sur le territoire tas pour des
gens qui ont eu zéro scolarité à des
gens qui ont des as clarté au niveau
universitaire c'est incroyable le nombre
de personnes quittant au nom de
personnes qui ont recherche actuellement
pour combler des postes et de tous
genres le travail et les vacances il ya
une différence mais il ya moyen de faire
les deux la même journée
un concept que le maire maîtrise
parfaitement aller pêcher en plein
centre ville
à cinq minutes du bureau pense que les
gens quand tu m'en vais ici vont tomber
en amour c'est avec laquelle du top 10
c'est tout le monde convient que ce prêt
sont loin de l'eau ici marichelles aux
ondes radio canada mont-laurier
[Musique]